on s'est battus contre le covid on nous
met à la rue
ubéritent les a quand même viré du jour
au lendemain et ben voilà et
ben
combien de personnes peuvent faire ça en
France dans le froid
[Applaudissements]
six étages
qui reconnaissent nos droits
salut c'est Juliette dans cette vidéo je
voulais vous parler du quotidien du
livreur de repas j'ai passé 48 heures
avec Thomas il a 30 ans il vit avec sa
femme et son nouveau-né et ça fait deux
ans qu'il est livreur tous les jours
Thomas livre des repas de 11h à 23h pour
gagner en moyenne 60 euros pour 12h de
travail c'est vraiment pas beaucoup
ouais bonsoir mon doigt comment tu vas
j'ai Antoine et Thomas s'il vous plaît
allez à tout à l'heure allez c'est parti
[Rires]
désolé
je suis vraiment désolé j'étais je vous
remercie monsieur et bon appétit passe
une agréable soirée c'est validé allez
c'est parti
ça va patron ça se passe
bon courage on va faire les grands
détours les routes sont barrées
[Musique]
allô bonsoir Monsieur oui c'est le
livret je suis là dans 10 secondes même
pas 5 secondes
bonsoir monsieur
si bon appétit bon on va à la place de
Clichy maintenant
je l'ai rencontré un soir à Paris sur
une place au lieu de ses collègues se
rassemblent en attendant leur prochaine
course quelle que soit la météo il sorte
j'ai une couche je dois livrer j'ai pas
le choix si j'annule les deux commandes
de me déconnecter
avant les plateformes payaient mieux ces
livreurs qui étaient souvent des
étudiants mais avec la baisse du prix de
la course de plus en plus de personnes
sans papiers ont repris ce boulot
difficile
vous savez qu'il y a des gens qui volent
des commandes ici ils se font passer oui
il se font passer pour les livreurs ils
viennent ils prennent des sacs ils sont
tous
à l'intérieur
merci beaucoup merci
je vous remercie à vous aussi on s'en va
la livraison non seulement c'est fatigué
et puis c'est mal payé
[Musique]
parce que tu restes toute une journée
sur un scooter ça fait mal au dos
ouais
on n'est pas la bonne adresse
[Musique]
sous oui souvent ça arrive on te dit
c'est ici mais c'est l'autre côté
vous voyez ça aussi la boisson c'est mal
fermée
on n'a pas trop fait de pavés
normalement les boissons mais souvent
quand on met les pouces comme ça c'est
nous on encaisse c'est pas le
restaurateur c'est vraiment je suis
désolé mais
bonne soirée à vous au moins lui il est
sympa sinon il y a des clients qui
disent NON je prends pas je prends pas
et quand je vais mettre commande
endommager lui il va me mettre un pouce
comme ça et c'est moins bien mes points
qui diminuent qui m'appelle allô
oui oui J'arrive madame 8h je vais vous
livrer tout à l'heure là
excusez-moi madame je suis désolé
mais enfin moi je fais 40 balles
désolé madame désolé
j'arrive tout de suite
sans nous on va livrer on a l'impression
que nous en fait on
n'a rien à dire quoi c'est comme nous on
est là on fait le travail comme ça et
puis voilà ceux qui sont pas contents et
nous jettent la pierre et puis nous on
est là nous on assume
il y a des restaurants qui sont sympas
qu'ils acceptent que nous rentrons dans
leur restaurant pour se réchauffer il y
a des restaurants aussi qui sont pas
sympas qui nous dit bah les livrets
c'est dehors voilà alors que nous nous
représentons les clients donc nous aussi
nous avons le droit de rentrer dans le
restaurant aller aussi récupérer notre
commande
je reviens
[Musique]
vous voyez le problème c'est que
les adresses sont pas précis en fait
vous voyez
oui oui
dans l'autre vous voyez alors que moi
ils m'ont mis là je vous remercie
monsieur vraiment il y a les clients qui
font ça bon appétit
tu manges quand tu travailles ou tu
attends toute la soirée tu manges que
quand tu rentres vers minuit
j'attends quand je rentre vers minuit ça
c'est porté hier et aujourd'hui je suis
à 51 euros même pas à 100 €. là je fais
ma dernière commande et puis je rentre
avec mes miettes que je gagne j'arrive à
me en tout cas à me défendre avec avec
ma petite famille j'ai pu laisser
peut-être 30 € à Madame elle va
s'arranger peut-être pour faire une
sauce avec du riz le soir pour qu'on
puisse manger
quand je commence à bâiller comme ça ça
veut dire que voilà
je commence à être fatigué là
un décédé Louis
chef s'il te plaît si c'est prêt tu peux
envoyer s'il te plaît je vois un sac qui
est prêt là les commandes sont là-bas
tant qu'ils n'ont pas encore fini de
tout faire ils vont pas ramener alors
que nous sommes pressés nous on
travaille avec le temps et tu veux aller
livrer pour aller te coucher mais ta
commande est là on te donne pas ouais et
quand c'est comme ça moi ça commence à
m'énerver je dis envoyer la commande dit
non attends alors que la commande est
déjà prête
ça c'est la réalité
déjà vous pouvez faire deux choses vous
pouvez descendre vous-même les escaliers
quand vous pouvez pour leur faire gagner
du temps et aussi penser à leur laisser
un petit pourboire Thomas en tout cas il
pense pas que c'est un bruit cotant
c'est plateformes qu'on trouvera la
solution chacun chacun a sa façon de
voir les choses si on a beaucoup de nous
on sait que c'est des gens on met au
chômage bah nous nous montrons nous on
veut pas les boycotter mais tout ce
qu'on nous on a à leur dire il faut
qu'ils essaient de remédier à la
situation en tout cas de d'arranger
beaucoup de choses la régularisation de
ceux qui n'ont pas de papier la
rémunération des des courses et puis le
respect et la considération aussi merci
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo j'espère
qu'elle vous a intéressé si jamais vous
voulez voir d'autres vidéos comme
celle-ci vous pouvez les retrouver sur
notre page YouTube et n'hésitez pas à
m'envoyer un message sur Instagram si
jamais vous avez des idées de d'autres
sujets que vous voudrez que je traite à
la prochaine vraiment c'est moi qui vous
remercie parce que à travers vous aussi
on peut voilà
vous contribuez à ce qu'on puisse
entendre nos voix aussi et voilà la
réalité à laquelle nous voilà nous
vivons
[Musique]